[Applause]
in april 2020
i made what many perceive as a risky
decision
i volunteered to be deliberately
infected with covert 19.
this infection would be part of what is
called a human challenge trial
where young healthy people are given a
vaccine and are deliberately exposed to
the virus that causes covert 19.
these trials help researchers figure out
more quickly if a vaccine is working
i think this research is crucial because
today i'm going to speak to you for six
minutes
in that time roughly 1250 people will be
confirmed infected with covet 19.
21 people will die and then this pattern
will repeat
hour after hour and day by day until
we're able to vaccinate
most of the 8 billion people affected by
this global crisis
scientists have been working around the
clock to make those vaccines
a reality but what should we do when the
human cost of waiting for those vaccines
is rising by the day this is where human
challenge trials come in
they're different from the traditional
phase 3 vaccine trials taking place now
where people are given a vaccine or
placebo and asked to go about their
everyday lives
here researchers have to wait to see how
many people
in each group become infected until
enough of them get sick
we don't have enough data to know
whether a vaccine is working
finding an effective vaccine with this
method can take months
or sometimes years and it requires
thousands of volunteers
a challenge trial works faster because
researchers control exposure
instead of waiting for people to get
sick so instead of
a year we could know in as little as a
month whether a vaccine
seems effective instead of thousands of
volunteers
a challenge trial relies on just 50 to
because we know for certain when people
are exposed and develop disease
these trials also allow us to gather
data about the early stages of infection
and our immune response this data is
impossible to gather in any other way
especially for people who become
infected but never show symptoms
this knowledge is important for
designing policies that limit covert 19
transmission
the time saved translates into precious
month's head start on manufacturing
getting us more working covert 19
vaccines faster
these trials are useful even though
recent phase 3 results sound encouraging
the arrival of the first vaccine is
going to be a monumental breakthrough
it just isn't quite the fairytale ending
we're all hoping for
we're going to need multiple vaccines
because we just don't have the
infrastructure
needed to immunize all 8 billion people
on the planet with just one kind
each type of vaccine requires its own
special process and equipment
to make store and deliver it
if we had multiple working covert 19
vaccines we could make use of all of our
equipment at the same time
some of the leading candidates need to
be kept extremely cold before they are
delivered to people
this can be really hard especially in
countries where there isn't reliable
electricity
or a secure method to store them
scientists have been using human
challenge trials for hundreds of years
they've sped up the development of
vaccines against typhoid and cholera
and they've helped us better understand
how immunity develops to things like the
flu
malaria and dengue we've even used them
for other types of coronavirus before
there's been a lot of debate about
whether challenge trials are too risky
i happen to think that those risks are
worth taking
a challenge trial would only recruit
young and healthy participants
think between the ages of 20 and 29.
fewer than one percent of people in that
age group need to be taken to hospital
after becoming infected with covert 19.
this would likely be even lower in a
challenge trial
because researchers check to make sure
that participants have no pre-existing
conditions
the risk of a young healthy person dying
of covert 19
is around 5 000 of a percent
that means for every 100 000 20 year
olds who become infected with covert 19
about five die if i were to give birth
in the united states
my risk of dying would be higher than
that
or you could choose to think about it
this way if my little sister needed a
kidney
i wouldn't hesitate for a moment before
i offered her mine
and if i can take on that risk to
benefit a loved one
it makes sense to allow people to take
on a similar risk
to speed up the development of a vaccine
that would benefit
not just their loved ones but everyone
around them
as well there's a lot we still don't
know especially about the long-term
effects of covert 19 infection
i volunteered despite that uncertainty
because like many of you i feel
frustrated
knowing that hundreds of thousands of
people are dying and that's without
mentioning the millions more
who are struggling as measures to stop
the spread take a toll
on their physical emotional and mental
well-being
it turns out i'm not alone in feeling
this way
since may over 39 000 people from across
the world
have volunteered to participate in
potential covert 19 challenge trials
through a non-profit i helped found
called one day sooner
we advocate for challenge trial
participants and have been encouraging
stakeholders to begin preparing for
these trials
as early as may when challenge trials
were still being considered for their
role
in the fight against covert 19 the
world's health organization
cited one day sooner as an example of
the kind of public engagement needed to
run a challenge trial
in mid-october the uk government
formally announced their intention
to conduct a challenge trial at the
beginning of 2021.
it is clear that the covert 19 pandemic
is a global crisis
it has inspired record-shattering
innovation and it has highlighted the
heroic acts of many frontline workers
but it has also taken a catastrophic
toll the arrival of each new vaccine
brings us one step closer to rebuilding
but the true
global solution lies in those vaccines
being in the hands of people
all over the world challenge trials
could be a part of that solution
thank you
you